first of all can I say
I cried I laughed like I felt all the
things everything
during this film I'm curious from you
like how are you able you think to
strike that almost perfect tone that
great balance between light and dark
throughout this whole film
I have the answer
I have the answer
Michael Showalter yeah that's the answer
um the director of this film is Michael
Showalter who we have both worked with
before he
um is he needs to have much more
recognition uh than he is
has received so far in his career I I
know that's it is on its way
um this is what he does this is his
territory he knows how to walk this very
delicate line between
High comedy and deep tragedy
um and he does it sort of effortlessly
and hands over the Reigns uh to the
actors allows them to find it
um but he's also the one that's there
you know there is somebody you know
you're gonna
bat it around with because you can
improv like crazy and love what you're
doing and he'll say I'm loving all of
that just don't do it
um so it's it's Michael Showalter
yeah when his name came up at the end of
the film I said of course
of course yeah
um
Bill how important was it for you to be
able to have
um Michael ostiello there as a resource
and to talk to you and to help guide
your performances especially in those
scenes like when you guys discovered the
truth about their relationship
I want you to ask Sally about a question
because she has a very pithy answer I
just found Michael's presence so
reassuring is both huge and very modest
his presence in the shooting
day and so you'd see him sort of over in
the corner and he would kind of Nod and
put his eyebrows up and you knew
we were in the right territory some of
these scenes were tricky and some of
them weren't and they just tumbled forth
with him looking on now ask Sally that's
any question
well I never looked at him I I
was there and that's a good thing but I
didn't want to know what he thought
um I didn't want to look over and see
and go ah because the
these even though they are authentic
people they are they exist in the world
today they're very private people and I
don't know if what we did was you know
verbatim or actually what happened
because we're really at service the the
characters that we play are really at
service to the to the story and to the
to the um kid character who's been
wonderfully paid by Ben Aldridge
um and so it we had to to me I had to
find it in the text and on stage with
Bill creating a character creating a
relationship and with with Ben
um so if it was accurate I didn't really
want to know it's not my task uh it's
not a historic person and that that
people are going to wait that's not she
didn't walk that way and talk that way
take it from the woman who played Mary
Lincoln you know it's both uh Sally just
knows how to find the strength and the
power but not be fettered by uh things
that might inhibit you as an actor
yeah that's wonderful well it worked
it's a beautiful performances from
everyone guys thank you so much for the
time thanks for chatting with you